>> So the question is whether India can become
a superpower.
I think, and I do think, yes.
We have everything going for India, both in
terms of a strong mandate
with a strong government in the near term,
the demographics, the
democracy, the language skills sets, the innovation,
the service
provider of most of the developed world.
I think what will hold us back will be our
weakness in implementation,
our deadlocked democracy, if not educated,
will turn back on us, which
is something we need to clearly focus on.
Education, health care, all these critical
if not dealt with and kept
to the last, will turn India into less of
a superpower than it can be.
Otherwise, I would say as far as I'm concerned,
if things work out, and
the level of optimism can be kept to a [INAUDIBLE]
certainly, most
certainly.